hey guys it's max with max tech you guys
asked for a photo on video comparison
between the last three generation of
iPhones and today we are delivering just
that I have the iPhone 10 the iPhone 10s
and the 11pro now we're starting out
doing some video clips here with the
front facing camera and the new iPhone
can shoot at 4k up to 60 frames per
second we're recording at 30 right now
let us know how it looks like and one
thing I'm seeing right now is the amount
of dynamic range the difference is
pretty substantial and not only that the
two so let me start moving around a
little bit right here and the iPhone 10
does not have extended dynamic range at
all even at 1080 thirty whereas the
tennis does have that and the new iPhone
even a 4k 30 it will feature that so
let's start walking we're gonna test out
a stabilization I'm gonna switch over to
my other hand and as we walk we can see
which one does a better job if you're
gonna do vlogging or anything like that
and I'm also switching between the
microphones as I you guys have seen so
you guys should be able to a difference
in audio quality or the microphone
recording quality now I'm gonna run up
this path again let's see how these gets
handled not only this harsh path I'm
running on with shaky footage but also
this crazy dynamic range here's an
example of 1080 60 on the 10s and 4k 60
on 11 Pro and of course on the 10 we can
only do a 1080p 30 frames per second
meaning that you want to slow something
down it's gonna be choppy or in regular
shooting it just won't be as smooth on
the 11 probe we also have the ability to
do slow fees at 1080p 120 frames per
second comparing the standard lens a
stabilization you see that the 11th pro
looks super stable almost like it's on a
gimbal where the others are wobbly and
here I'm literally running super fast
and iPhone 11 is very impressive and
this one is with the telephoto once
again much improved and of course we
have the ultra ride with a cinematic
stabilization that looks super smooth
like a gimbal not only does the 11pro
have better details but the sky is also
visible thanks to better dynamic range
compared to blow now on the other two
once again we have more detail in more
saturated colors just like the iPhone 10
where the
hen ass is really flat in this autofocus
test the exposure is all over the place
really glitchy on iphone 10 much
improved in the 10s but perfectly smooth
on the 11pro not only is the dynamic
range really improved especially on
themes for head but the f11 pros new
ultra wide lens really allows us to
capture the scene when we're standing on
the small dock now let's test the new
mic zoom feature at this waterfall
[Music]
getting into photos this standard shot
doesn't look too different between the
off colors taking a portrait shot the 11
Pro does better with edge detection and
also keeps this whole jacket and pants
sharp whereas the 10s really like to
blur the foreground elements the Levin
pro also maintains more detail in the
face and better highlight roll-off
looking more realistic and of course
with 11 Pro we can also shoot photos
using the standard lens which really
shows off the location now for some
landscape shots and as you see the ultra
wide lens really gives us a really nice
perspective here showing off the whole
location
comparing the standard lenses iPhone 10s
is flatter with less saturation than
iPhone 10 & 11 Pro kicks it up a notch
further than the 10 with the 10s we
always complained about a lack of
contrast and saturation
it looks like Apple finally listened and
delivered the 11 pro's telephoto lens
gives us the best of both of the other
phones that in a Mac range of the 10s
with a nice brighter highlights of the
iPhone 10 for a really nice looking
image and next i zoomed in 10 times to
check out the quality difference and the
detail here I shot right into the Sun
with the standard lens and the iPhone 10
has the best contrast surprisingly the
flaring and the 11pro
does have the least flaring but also
loses contrast in the center now time
for a macro shot and the difference here
is dramatic not only does the 11pro
maintain all of the texture the detail
of the object the little flower thing
I'm shooting but we also aren't blowing
anything out and it's much more detailed
whereas the f1 10 and 10
really kind of blow out the image and
all the texture that we see there is
just completely lost this shot was a
very interesting one I have 110 looks
great on the face maybe a little bit too
bright but nice texture whereas the
colors were kind of off in the foliage
the tennis really focuses on the colors
of the foliage but the face has no
texture no shadowing and really weird
colors that it picked up whereas the
other cameras and gives us a great
detailed image with really good colors
now it's time for a portrait selfie
Apple made a ton of changes this year
the biggest most obvious one is probably
the amount of blur in the background it
is way more than before I actually
prefer the iPhone 10 s is blur but of
course you can tweak that in post
the next thing is that in the hair and
the shadows I can still see all the
hairs instead of being pure black and
the detail in my face and in my facial
hair is really much more than before now
another change is that the jacket is no
longer blurred out like Apple used to do
on iphone 10 and 10 s here's a regular
portrait shot that shows a really
dramatic difference the skin tones in
detail are much better on iphone 10 and
even better on the 11pro wears a 10 s
the smart HDR is making it kind of flat
and one thing you'll notice on the left
hand side of a team's face the 11pro
really messes up on the blur and I think
it's because it's cranked up to about
detection as good but then the detail on
the shirt and the jacket are much better
and of course with 11pro we have the
ability to shoot portraits with the
standard lens which really shows off the
location in this portrait the extra blur
looks really nice with the nice leading
walkway you'll also notice more detail
and if we punch in that is very visible
especially in the hair the iPhone 10
completely blows out the right side of
his face and it lacks detail it just has
a little bit too much sharpening the
iPhone tennis looks a lot better and the
the highlight roll off and the
shattering in the face looks much more
natural and like an actual camera all
three phones nailed this very difficult
portrait shot of these posts the edging
is really good and you do notice a
difference in the amount of blur from
the 10 to the 10s to 11pro it increases
with every generation
by default and of course with the 11pro
antennas you can actually tweak that
blur in post whereas the iPhone 10 you
cannot adjust that and it looks so much
better with 11 Pro having that extra
blur now another difference is that we
now have high key mono available it
doesn't look great for this shot but at
least it's able to pull it off where it
looks weird on the 10s and of course we
don't have that with the 10 and in this
last shot of the waterfall this really
just shows off how much more you can
capture compared to having a standard
lens not only that we have a little bit
more contrast a little more saturation
with 11pro and a lot more of the cloud
detail up above the iPhone 11 pros
telephoto lens has been dramatically
improved we could tell that in this 10x
zoom not only does the sine look a lot
more detailed and the digital zooming
the algorithm is much better we just get
so much more detail on the sine and also
in the background with the trees where
she's kind of blurred out with other
ones here's another example of the 11pro
taking the best of both worlds from the
contrast on the face but blue at the
highlights 10s did better with the
highlights but it was really flat
whereas love and pro maybes a little bit
too contrasty but definitely a nice
out-of-the-box photo that you don't have
to edit now it's time to test low-light
we are gonna start off with video in
here this is 4k 60 that is slowed down
you could see how much better the
stabilization is in this slow motion
instead having little jitters like the
smooth not only that but we also have a
lot better dynamic range where as the
lights on the inside are retained
instead of being blown out and with less
noise as well with really low light the
iPhone 10 has a ton of noise the 10 s
kind of improves on that and 11 Pro has
the least amount of noise and is also
the brightest now for some low-light
photos you can see the Red Robin sign is
completely blown out on iPhone 10 we
start seeing some color with the 10s and
with the iPhone 11 Pro it actually looks
just like it does in real life exposing
for the Starbucks sign if you look below
you could see how dark the shots are on
the 10 and the 10s
whereas 11 Pro has much better dynamic
range to maintain that detail and if we
expose for the shadows you could see
that the 11 Pro has more detail but then
if we crop in how much of the highlights
are still
retained because of the better dynamic
range the same thing goes for this shot
where the iPhone 10 literally blows out
the dobby sign you can't even read it
the 10s a little bit better but the
much better colors and contrast with
better details as well with this shot we
have a dramatic difference where the
iPhone 10 not only makes a net super
dark the background in the picture is
actually blown out at the same time the
keeps all of the details in the
background and makes her in her clothes
much brighter and more colorful in this
selfie the iPhone 10 blows out the whole
background so he can't even tell that
it's an Apple Store the tennis is a bit
better and the levant Pro is even better
maintaining all of the dynamic range and
having a little bit better colors as
well another massive difference with the
iPhone 10 giving us a really dark image
when using portrait mode and blowing out
the background the 10s is a little bit
better with its f 2.4 lens but the new f
the 11pro gives us a bright sharp and
colourful image with good dynamic range
and once again we are able to use the
standard lens which really shows off the
location but also it's better in
low-light giving us a lot more detail
and less noise and even without night
mode the 11pro is able to capture so
much more light than the other two
phones can so we can actually see the
subject that we're taking a photo of now
finally let's get into night mode and
one thing I love about the iPhones night
mode is that it still looks like it's
nighttime it doesn't make it look like
daytime it just increases the colors the
contrast and the details this image
really shows off what night mode is
capable of not only do we have accurate
colors from the street lights we also
see stars in the sky we have much more
detail in the shadows if the whole image
is brighter and more colorful instead of
being either too dark or with really off
colors and odd texture in the sky but
the trees have so much more detail and
you can see those little stars instead
of being all smeared this was taken in a
very dark closet and you could see the
makes the image look like the light was
turned on another dramatic difference
here with night mode we see so much more
detail it actually looks like an image
that is usable compared to the 10s which
looks really bad in the tent which looks
horrendous
all the iphones do a surprisingly good
job in this dark interior shot the 11pro
of course has more detail a little bit
more colors and contrast so it looks
better but with 11pro we also have the
ability to shoot with the ultra wide
lens this lets us capture the whole
scene but of course it is not as good in
low-light so we do have some denoising
and less details overall the same thing
goes for this location where the
ultra-wide lens lets us capture the
whole scenery instead of just a small
crop so thank you guys for watching let
us know if any of these comparison
images really stood out to you we would
love to hear you guys as opinions and
click above to subscribe and down below
two naval notifications if you guys want
to see videos in the future on the right
hand side we have some really solid
suggestions if you guys want to see
something else this has been max with
max tech and I will see you in the next
video
[Music]